aber es macht klack macht keinen penis
falls das wissen ist auch clever alter
klar dass davor warte ja mobil alters
kann es auch oben gucken dann xbox
treffen stück journalisten mit
hauptsache die xbox und wagenrad von in
summe mit natürlichen karen oder so
jo leute herzlich willkommen zum ersten
stunde in der waldorfschule und heute
machen wir wie man es in der nein das
habe ich sagen heute machen wir egal
also ganz ohne ware ohne waldorfschule
machen wir mal an mit bongos sind hier
in münster und ich bin gerade irgendwie
okay gut selbst ganz selbstständig
gelöst okay das ist wissen jackie sage
jetzt mal ein halt dein stachel maßstabs
wir ich alle texte übrigens auch am
start ja ich bin also fokussiert aus
marl und ihr seid eine scheiße weil es
nicht geraten hat oh mein gott oh mein
gott der dich connected keine ahnung
du bist nicht das freut mich schon mal
und da gibt es so kurz zu sagen hat ist
alles bisschen ungewohnt gerade weil ich
jetzt an
maxis pc aufnehmen muss an kann ich wenn
mein laptop wie ihr vielleicht wirst
bisschen stress gemacht den letzten
tagen dann schreibe ich gleich mal aus
und machte den staub raus und jo bis
dahin nehme ich jetzt mal hier mal auf
und der bildschirm tausend mal größer
als meine mindestens doppelt so groß und
ich komme gar nicht lang aber dafür boxe
ich jetzt leute hier zum beispiel sehr
comics
ja das mit dabei freundchen bei dir kann
man auf dich kann man immer zählen zur
schlägerei gibt es da man so genau
meinem allen alter der mutter her
deine mutter deine mutter jo-jo im
hintergrundchor schüler so wechsel kam
mit nein ganzes ja das ist ein alter in
mauls geschlossen
das ist doch clever alter klar dass
davor warte ja höher desto weiter kann
es auch oben gucken darf xxxx box stück
stadtmitte hauptsache die xbox live aus
wie so ein wagenrad von insm mit
natürlichen karen oder so egal aber
danke für den tipp dass da oben hin
schon kann das wusste ich bisher noch
nicht sondern machen immer weiter mit
eskalation und boxen leute es kann man
bald ihr wisst ihr wisst alter ja wie
gesagt waldorfschule über die leute so
bescheuert sind deswegen sagen normal
mangos das ist nicht grundlos so gewählt
wurde der name nun einen besonderen
fähigkeiten ja von hinten kommt der ja
ich hab's geraten alleine halte die
schnauze halten da nicht noch als jetzt
sagt dass ich einen tipp bekommen
bestimmt nicht das war mein alter ego
ich bin sehr zufrieden
ich hab mit anderer stimme gesprochen
hast du musst mal in die waldschule
junger schickte nicht mehr wie eine uni
ge auf gewalt oder [ __ ] nicht mit mir
ich glaube meine begriffe wie ich
zufrieden die kennt dann darf man nicht
die waldorfschule rot das ist eine
cherry und ersten hände ändern ein
ändern kannst nicht hoffen da braucht
man einen cocktail länder geraten oder
doch hat eine geraten egal
man kann halt im alter ich erstaunt auf
den letzten platz voll schlecht
ach so wird man muss man scores hier ich
bin hat nur einen punkt man vor der fed
cup schon am 3 die stars lernen lernen
ist das ist der spaß soll mama hast doch
gold oder wieso machst wieder wegmachen
paul korn
ja geil black black ich schreib mal ist
wahrscheinlich würde ich immer sagen
zuerst raul vernehmen ganz gechillt
jungen alter für jedes budget für jedes
für das dumme gemalte teil der vorne
krieg einer hier in der rundumschlag
ungefähr jeden penis der nicht ran
schreibt clixoom stark box dich vorher
und vor durchboxen kann gerade mal
schauen was geht ist das lernen was zur
hölle eltern was zur hölle war kurz zur
seite
ich muss das erst mal dran ihr durch
schnauze
aber was hat das hindern ja mein alte
gold gesagt dass ich das in den chat
schreiben sollten raten soll was es ist
ihr seht es zu einem video aber für die
ich nicht gesehen haben seit der
domvikar natürlich muss man das einfach
so dass ein ja ich sag's gleich wenn das
wort kommt das ist ein schornstein jimmy
auf englisch ja genau das eine gute idee
von firmen behinderten tippen dass ich
aber mal auf einmal übersetzen was für
euer alter ich möchte bitte die
wirtschaftliche hätte das ist ja nicht
so drin weil dir deswegen ist die
schnauze geweckt in lernen gewohnt bist
dann immer diese schlägereien hierbei
jumping doch glaube ich der einzige der
box oder boxen will so das ist ein
schmetterling wasser fährt schlag mal
vor ausbau menschen sind jeder sommer
schleck schleck markt ja der bin ich
wieder weg
ok also das ziemlich offensichtlich dass
eine banane ist eine geistige
behinderung
wir werden uns das in keiner weise
richtig goldig und agency ja ich musste
ich mal überholen junge ohne scheiß mich
hier keiner also her heißt das ist ihr
allerdings mal englisch reicht aber
jetzt reicht's ich die sache mal war
dafür warte ja ich hab mir gesagt okay
ich es auch von der zeit her meinte ja
von zeit haben daran was bist du denn
was macht deine mama stolz texte und
schwierig wird ganz schön lange 6 10 12
minuten dürften es werden elf minuten
stehen gold sonne
was ist der basar sollten sonne seiten
der mitte ist nötig vielleicht hey was
soll das sein danken schnell bereit sein
leid
gott ich habe geschrieben wie schlecht
leider versteht neid macht ihr willst
wirst jetzt mahlzeit consulter dieser
runde bin ich voll schlecht
theoretisch aber wenn ich jetzt einmal
das ging als er sich ja jeder wunsch
mein letzter platz da ging ich hab dich
12 punkte oder so ich habe diese scheiße
schon mal aufgenommen mit user sind dann
durch sein aber vergessen zu exportieren
schüssel war eine andere wunde meister
nicht mal am start ja ja ja wieso erhöht
ist jetzt schon ein alter da pro laptop
dafür alter bitte leute wenn ihr nicht
mal könnt dann verpasst es geht doch
nicht so ein scheiß ich meine so was
kann man doch nicht erraten der iss
erwartet wahrscheinlich im teamspeak
oder
jan-peter organe mit dem typen da nicht
abgesprochen mit dem ich bin zweiter
platz verlor eine absprache
stattgefunden ich muss einfach den
scheiß zweimal erraten
dann habe ich ja beschlossen
romane so jung
es war so knapp ich schwöre es war so
knapp
der wert die drei punkte bekommen wir
sind erst auf platt mich dass das das
soll das ist konzept mal mit
vom stadthotel wissen gesteuert hieß
auto
ex-model holy [ __ ] you sit ja schöne
verändert
es geht ja nicht darum dass man hier
irgendwelche bilder erregt haben sich um
die für die leute hier aufregt in
welcher für eine scheiße machen
in diesem sinne waren erfolgreich es war
nicht ganz so toll wie die letzte die
letzte aufnahme leider gefällt
ich würde sagen das wiederholen wir noch
mal wenn es euch gefallen hat neigt man
sich nicht gefallen hat kritik in die
kommentare
lasst mich das wissen und servus mach's
gut